a special guest here to share his
appreciation ladies and gentlemen
Buffalo Bills safety Demar Hamlin
days after Damar Hamlin's Super Bowl
appearance he's addressing the
controversial varsity jacket he wore to
the big game
the piece of clothing which features a
depiction of a crucified Jesus on the
back was first criticized by fellow NFL
player Adrian Peterson he called it
Blasphemous and disrespectful and now
Demars responding on Twitter explaining
that after talking with his parents he
understands how the jacket could be
offensive and adds it was never his
intention to hurt or disrespect anyone
so who's the designer behind the coat
well it's from a collaboration between
Travis Scott an artist Takashi murakami
by the brand St Michael the front has an
image of Jesus too similar to a chain
the rappers holding in this pick but for
tomorrow he says the jacket is abstract
art to him quote it says Eternal which I
am eternally thankful to my savior Demar
says his beliefs in relationship with
God isn't tied to symbolic images but
nonetheless he's learned his lesson and
will continue to walk in love do you
want to get yourself back on the
football field
uh eventually you know that's that's
always the goal but uh I'm allowing that
to be in God's hands
demo on the road to recovery after
suffering Cardiac Arrest during a game
January 2nd we understand the the
significance of the injury and the
situation his injury was met with an
outpouring of love from fans all around
the world and during tomorrow's
hospitalization he says he was reminded
of his purpose what happened to me on
Monday Night Football I feel as a direct
example of God using me as a vessel to
share my passion and my love directly
from my heart with the entire world and
I'm able to give it back to kids and
communities all across the world who
need it the most demar's toy drive
fundraiser raised more than 8.6
dollars in donations you put Humanity
above team loyalty you showed the world
Unity over division I'm not surprised by
it but I'm deeply grateful and I'll be
forever thankful and indebted to that I
think our society is starting to come
around and doing you know being an
athlete is just a platform it's an entry
point to a larger Mission or purpose
that you can serve and I think the Mars
the perfect example of that and Mars
being recognized for his work last week
he was honored with the community award
at the NFL honors ceremony Southern
Cardiac Arrest was nothing I would have
ever chosen to be a part of my story but
that's because sometimes our own Visions
are too small even when we think we are
seeing a bigger picture at
I can tell you it's possible it's a
tough situation uh they you know it's
they can't really tell because it's like
it's a up to me thing I guess or or you
know it's it's just it's a long road
they just were worrying about trying to
get me back to normal
um as as much as they can
[Music]